well I can tell you a little bit what
our first experiences were when we had
determined to first structure by NMR the
first reaction was that it cannot be
done that was the reaction from the site
of crystallographers and this is also
documented in writing so it must be it
must be a modeling using information
from crystal structures the second
problem arose because we solved the
second structure the first structure was
bull seminal inhibitor that's a small
very stable molecule from bull semen and
that that's just globular structure and
there were analogues of which the
crystal structures had been solved so
the suggestion was that we had used
information from these homologues second
structure resolved was metallothionein
and they turned out that unknown to us
the crystal structure had been solved
and the two were completely different it
is so that in metallothionein you have
seven metal ions in a small globular
structure of 60 to 62 amino acids the
monkeys are 20 sustains these are amino
acids with an SH group in the side chain
and these 20 sustains would coordinate
bind in coordinate of Lee to those seven
metal ions which means at some systems
are bound to Morrison bond metaline so
so called bridging sustains and of the
28 metal two amino acid coordinate if
bones 21 were different between the
crystal structure
here and our structure so journal
Science got submissions of both
structures decided that the
crystallographers must be right because
it's an established technique can be
must just have plundered and they
publish the crystal structure and
rejected our structure which was then
published in housing journal Molecular
Biology and we'd ends of two more
metallus Ionians which I mean the first
one was a rabbit then we had the human
and I think I'm not sure now of the
third species they were all identical it
took crystallography six years to reduce
the structure and find it to be
identical to ours that was the second
part of the game when the first when
this was our timing the criticism that
we had used the information from
homologous structures and then the
problem is metallothionein late robert
rubin who got a nobel prize in 1988 for
the reaction center he suggested let's
clean this up we take one unknown
protein and I Souls the crystal
structure and use all see any more
stretch being sure that we couldn't do
it and so with it and the two structures
turn out to be identical and that gave
rise to a very long publication and
journal Molecular Biology I think 70
pages with all the details of sir animo
structure determination and then it was
resolved then there was an editorial
comment by Sydney Brenner was the chief
editor he said now we have published a
complete description of an animal
structure
termination of a protein we will never
again do that from now on we will
publish notices similar to those for
crystal structures so at that point it
was all set but you say took four years
of doubts and and criticism